okay the last question
nate grundman can you imagine
referring to you michael can you imagine
a mental practice by which a person can
influence the goal state of the body for
example joe dispenza has made some
claims that he's healed his body in a
way that doctors say are impossible and
also a question i had for you earlier
which relates to this is
how
your work is related to the placebo
effect
so
whether or not you see the connection
there i'm interested in the placebo
effect too i'm trying to sneak in two
questions for the pressure one
yeah um okay so so i i don't know
anything about uh joe dispenza i don't
know anything about the claims that he's
made or any specific uh you know kind of
uh healing event
but i'll give you kind of a general
thought about this
it is
uncontroversial
that
your your thoughts whatever they may be
whether or not you know whatever
whatever you think thinking is it is
pretty uncontroversial that your
thoughts affect the physiological
functioning of your body i mean that's
obvious if you if you want to get up and
walk around your thoughts have now
activated various uh electrical pathways
they've triggered a bunch of muscle
motion if you have a tendency to you
know mentally work yourself up into an
anxious state you can certainly by by by
your thinking uh crank up various stress
enzyme production in your body right we
all know that you can do the opposite if
you if you've trained in techniques to
calm yourself down under various
circumstances you can uh reduce the
level of cortisol in your blood you can
reduce um various uh various fire and
flight responses so it's it's it's not
some some some weird um you know of a
voodoo kind of claim to uh to say that
that your thoughts absolutely affect the
biophysical processes of your body we do
it every day if that wasn't true you
couldn't get up in the morning when you
wanted to get up and go to work so so
it's it's that part's completely obvious
so from there
it's a very short uh hop skip and a jump
to the idea that not only can you give
commands to your muscles and your glands
to produce various
hormones neurotransmitters and muscle
motion but you might be able to exert
some influence over other cells for
example skin cells um in your uh you
know at wounds and and uh and you and
your liver the in the way that it
processes information uh i don't find it
implausible whatsoever so i don't again
i'm not commenting on any particular
instance of anybody having healed
themselves of anything i'm just saying
that
it is it is uh it is it is not
uh it is not a stretch to think that not
only can you talk to your va
when i say talk i mean you know exert
exert influence
on your uh on your various glands that
that put out cortisol and adrenaline and
various other things
why can't why can't you send commands to
other cells i that that seems it seems
silly to think that that's impossible
so um
having said all that i think that uh the
placebo effect is extremely profound i
think that what it's telling us is that
there is a communication across levels
so you have meaning that you have a
level of organization that consists of
your body cells and that has a degree of
cognition and a degree of intelligence
but your body is also home to an
additional intelligence which lives
probably largely in the brain
and it appears that those two can uh can
communicate in various ways and i can
imagine that
there are new
there are lots of things to be
discovered about ways to improve that
communication and have you know we know
we know there are certain practices
where people extend the amount of time
they can they can sit under water and
and change their body temperature and
and change their their pulse rate and
things like that i find it completely
plausible that that there are ways to
uh
communicate in that way to other cells
in the body
also
uh
there is the there is the field of um
hypno dermatology where where people by
hypnosis try to treat various skin
diseases some of which have a neural
neuroimmune component some of which may
not have a neuroimmune component
so um the activity of of the mind which
is simply the execution of of the
physiological um computations that
happen in the brain affect physiological
computations that happen outside the
brain i don't think that's i don't think
that's particularly a stretch uh at all
one of your goals is an anatomical
compiler and then what you just said
made me think well some of these people
who are meditating or on the more
meditative side tend to work with
thoughts to heal oneself and then i was
wondering hmm i wonder if your
anatomical compiler can advise some of
the more thought-based healing practices
here's an example you say well if you
were to think of this image it's more
likely to heal you than if you were to
think of this other image do you think
that's at all possible or that's way too
high level
i don't think it's i don't think it's
impossible no uh
again i'm not suggesting that there's
i'm not supporting any particular image
of as being a healing one but i don't
think it's it's impossible at all i mean
the
uh and and there's been work recently on
various types of um pulsed light stimuli
into the retina having some some
interesting neuro
neuroprotective effects in the brain and
so on um yeah all of this it's it's a
giant electrical network all of the
cells are communicating with each other
uh there's absolutely no reason why that
couldn't work
but i think that um you know to to be
clear this anatomical compiler isn't
just us you know
the anatomical compiler is a
it's a sort of practical um
personification of the goal that all of
us in the community are going for which
is the ability to control growth and
form right and and when we have that
ability that's when the anatomical
compiler becomes positive possible so
it's not just something that we you know
we in particular are working on but i
think that uh this is this is part of
all the things you're discussing now are
part of the deep reason why
cognitive science and consciousness and
all of those kinds of things are deeply
related to developmental biology and
physiology right they're they're
absolutely interrelated because they are
two sides of the same coin information
processing in goal directed hierarchical
systems and when you understand the more
you understand about one the better you
are at managing the others this is this
is two sides of the same question